this guy's got go he's got a good
question okay here we go a lot of our
questions stay at their shirts off I
don't know what it is but people are
fired up yeah they're do it you come
push-ups Sean what is your favorite
tattoo um prize a price on my face I
remember when I want I want to get face
tattoo Danny my girl she's like nah
don't do it and it was the star in it
I said I'm stupid enough to get a face
tattoo but I was smart enough to get a
fake one first right so I got the fake
star tattoo before my fight with Andre
and it was I'm like damn I like that so
so I went got the star I was feeling
like a [ __ ] superstar yeah I was on
pay-per-view I'm in the UFC is 22 years
old I'm like [ __ ] I'm getting a star on
my face I ever work a [ __ ] job again
so I'm probably the star that's what
started the face tattoos and then I got
and I got sugar and then I got breathe
it says breathe when you look in the
mirror uh-huh that one was pretty cool
because I was going to like all that you
saw the stuff I was really learning more
about my breath and meditation and
stoicism
and it all comes back to just taking
that just breathing and feeling that
breast so I got that one I liked that
one a lot then I got the heart the heart
was just kind of like oh I just want
something on my face yeah man that's
feeling hard yeah do what you got to do
yeah because I mean back in there like I
mean tattoos and stuff I don't have
anybody sick with a little faced at
tribal thing really yeah dawg I know but
something some small would be sick yeah
I think you gotta even if you get like a
little fake one first just to check it
out yeah I'd like it you look in the
mirror you scream I do every morning
do you yeah it feel hard because you're
like [ __ ] I have to show up now that I
have face tattoos Wow after that and not
show up for like my fight before my
fight like I got [ __ ] crazy hair I
get knocked out that's gonna be [ __ ]
a meme for everything laying there my
hair flop around yeah colorful evening
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw I
mean it was okay but the next video you
can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watches one